bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france comment expliquer cette
forte montée du nombre de cas d' en
espagne alors écoutez je savais que vous
alliez m'interroger sur ce sujet j'ai
donc regardé et consulté l'institut de
statistique de déclaration des cas et
comme toujours il faut être très
attentif
en matière de chiffres est ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que ce chiffre
aujourd'hui de 5000 cas qui est annoncée
quotidien et en partie faux puisque il
comprend à la fois les résultats qui
sont déclarés en termes de pcr et en
termes de sérologie le vrai chiffre de
cas effectivement diagnostiqué par pcr
est aujourd'hui d'environ 1800 c'est à
dire qu'il est à la hauteur du nombre de
cas déclarés en france servent dans un
pays plus petits milles et 2800 et ce
qui fait monter et obtenir ce chiffre de
ce sont les autres résultats qui
s'agrège qui sont les résultats de
sérologie dont on sait qu'ils sont un
peu moins fiable pour certifier
effectivement par exemple la date de
contamination ou l'activité effective de
la contamination du coronavirus alors
selon nos informations on sera à peu
près dans la même configuration qu'en
france ça signifie quand même qu'il ya
bien une crainte d'une seconde vague
épidémique en espagne alors c'est vrai
mais là encore il faut effectivement à
10 et les chiffres avec prudence ce
qu'on voit sur le terrain très
clairement c'est que deux semaines en
arrière on a vu réapparaître au niveau
de notre activité des cas de positivité
au corps à nos virus qui avait quasiment
disparu à la suite du confinement et on
a vu apparaître ces positivité et depuis
maintenant une semaine
eh bien on voit réapparaître des cas de
patients qui sont essoufflés
c'est-à-dire qu'ils développent une
forme sévère de la maladie
donc c'est vrai que si l'évolution se
poursuit dans ce sens là on peut
s'attendre effectivement à voir
réapparaître des cas graves d'ici quinze
jours trois semaines
d'ailleurs sur le plan des chiffres
aujourd'hui l'espagne a déclaré environ
60 morts sur la journée d'hier
deux patients du coronavirus alors que
ce chiffre début juillet étaient
d'environ 8 à 9 sur le plan quotidien
en france on évoque une deuxième vague
et puis des milk possible à l'automne en
hiver c'est un peu la même chose en
espagne
si vous voulez de toute façon l'épidémie
à l'aide européenne et on n'a pas de
raisons effectivement de ne pas vivre
les mêmes dynamique épidémique dans les
différents pays européens
ce qui est certain et ce qui est
trompeur aujourd'hui c'est que
évidemment la récolte des chiffres n'est
plus du tout la même que au début de
l'épidémie où par exemple on ne
comptabilisait pas les asymptomatiques
aujourd'hui on comptabilise les
asymptomatique et donc les chiffres
qu'on a aujourd'hui et qui paraissent
élevés sont encore sans doute
relativement en dessous de ce qu'ils
étaient les chiffres lors de la première
vague donc si deuxième vague il y a si
la croissance de l'épidémie continue sur
le rythme actuel on peut s'attendre à
voir à nouveau des images de décès dans
les hôpitaux qui avaient frappé
l'opinion publique lors de la première
vague je vous dit probablement d'ici
trois semaines un mois
ça veut dire quoi en niveau justement de
des règles sanitaires des mesures pour
contrer là là là le risque d'une
nouvelle épidémie est ce qu un nouveau
confinement est envisagée dans le pays
par exemple
alors c'est vrai qu'ici tout le monde
veut éviter un deuxième confinement car
l'économie aujourd'hui est à terre on
voit bien dans les rues de barcelone
qu'il ya très peu de touristes
de nombreux commerces sont restés fermés
60% des hôtels n'ont même pas ouvert
durant la saison touristique donc
personne n'ose imaginer aujourd'hui un
deuxième confinement mais c'est vrai que
personne aujourd'hui n'a la maîtrise de
ce qui va se passer dans les mois qui
viennent et tout reste suspendu
effectivement à l'efficacité des mesures
sanitaires qui sont actuellement
appliquées et sur les règles sanitaires
que pouvez-vous
dire on voit quand en europe le port
obligatoire du masque dans les espaces
publics se généralise alors sur le port
du masque vraiment par exemple quand on
regarde les commentaires à la suite des
reportages qui sont diffusées sur ans
sur votre antenne on voit que pour un
certain nombre de personnes le port du
masque est contesté c'est à dire que
certaines personnes pensent encore que
le mec ne colle masque n'est pas
efficace contre la transmission des
virus
il y a donc encore une pédagogie à faire
sur ce plan là mais c'est vrai aussi que
les téléspectateurs et les français ne
sont pas des moutons et qu'ils
aimeraient avoir un discours parfois
plus claires et c'est vrai que le tout
masque parfois dessert aussi le message
qui consiste à une utilisation
effectivement efficace du masque
effectivement quand on est seul dans la
rue certains peuvent difficilement
comprendre pourquoi on leur impose le
port du masque mais vos recommandations
en matière de règles sanitaires très
rapidement alors matière de règles
sanitaires c'est assez simple c'est à
dire que effectivement il faut porter le
masque quand on est en réunion quand on
est en contact avec d'autres personnes
que ces personnes soient symptomatique
ou non surtout si on étend en face à
face à moins de deux mètres par exemple
en revanche ou pas la peine je pense de
porter le masque sur une plage si on est
suffisamment distancié ou si on a l'air
libre etc ont effectivement marche dans
un espace ou peu denses en revanche qui
est fondamentale et on insiste beaucoup
sur le masque mais moi je pense qu'il
est fondamental effectivement de
continuer à se laver les mains plusieurs
fois par jour
car peu de gens le disent peu de
médecins le disent sur les antennes mais
il faut savoir que ce virus on la
trouvait également dans les selles on
l'a trouvé dans le sperme et donc la
transmission de ce virus se fait
également par le portage
des maladies fécales c'est à dire par la
transmission des mains également en
quelques secondes vraiment avant de se
quitter
le nouveau vaccin russe qui a été
annoncé hier qu'en pensez vous écoutez
ça soulève quand même un enthousiasme
généralisé car tout le monde attend ce
vaccin et tout le monde espère bien
qu'un vaccin va mettre fin à cette
épidémie donc pas d'à priori mais
évidemment une interrogation de la
communauté internationale quant aux
procédures qui ont été suivies quant aux
preuves scientifiques d'efficacité de ce
vaccin
il est trop tôt pour porter un jugement
et il faut bien sûr attendre les
prochaines informations qui seront
données sur l'efficacité et l'innocuité
de ce vaccin
merci avons philippe-emmanuel il avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin basée à
barcelone